and tonight while the Biden State
Department twiddling its thumbs the
State of Florida got to work why they're
evacuating Americans from Israel as War
has erupted in the region here with
Moore is 2024 presidential candidate
Florida Governor Ronda Santos Governor
great to have you back first tell us
what you were doing for Florida
residents uh that have found themselves
without commercial flight availability
to come
home well you know Sean it was sad
because the state department and the
embassy over in Israel were not helpful
to these people you think about it
illegal aliens come across our Southern
border federal government will fly them
all over the country for free they'll
put them up in nice hotels uh taxpayer
expense free to the illegal alien and
yet the best that they were able to do
for the people caught Americans caught
in Israel uh was to either dump them in
Cyprus or in Greece and then charge them
for that and then they just have to
somehow get home so uh we did an
executive order at the end of last week
said we'll mobilize our emergency
response folks uh we'll get planes there
to bring Floridians back home from
Israel and so we were able to land the
first plane last night 271 people and
the thing about it my wife and I were
there at Tampa Airport welcoming people
back there were 91 children on that
plane Sean I mean uh I had a woman come
up to me saying you know her
six-year-old daughter was saying you
know I don't want to hear any more
Rockets I want to go back to Florida I
need to get back to Florida and so we
were able up to fill the void there was
no leadership and so we step up and we
LED Governor let me ask you a lot has
been made over comments you made I think
it was on CVS we cannot accept people
from Gaza well frankly we can't accept
people from anywhere because of Joe's
open borders and it'll be 8 million
total by the end of this year uh into
this country is refugees you said in
Iowa you said you're not going to do
that if you look at how they behave not
all of them are heras but all of them
are a are all anti-semitic and I know
the media's jumped on you from that one
of of the things we've shown on this
program and maybe I interpreted it
differently we've shown the cartoons and
as you're giving your answer I'll show
that to the this audience as well and
there there is an
indoctrination in
cartoons and in books at the youngest
ages and these kids are being taught to
hate the Jews and even kill the Jews uh
that indoctrination is
real exactly so we're no my position is
very clear as the first president TR C
to say no Gaza refugees period we're
just not going to do it and why because
we don't want to import the pathologies
from the Gaza Strip and other places in
the Middle East to the United States of
America they are taught to hate Jews
they are taught that Israel has no right
to exist the textbooks that they use
don't even have Israel on the map at all
and so this is just endemic to their
culture it's a really toxic culture
that's developed so there's no reason to
be importing that into the United States
and the idea that we can kind of
separate like a terrorist from some
someone that may be a freedom lover that
just doesn't work uh so so we will not
do that uh when I'm president all right
last question what should America's role
be here in your
view I think it's supporting Israel for
their right to get the job done you
pointed out something that's absolutely
true Biden is saying we support Israel
but behind the scenes they're trying to
kneecap what they're doing they have a
right to eliminate Hamas and we should
stand with them uh it's moral Clarity
you can't have moral equivalence between
Hamas and the Israeli civil uh and is
killing Israeli civilians it's just
wrong we also have to say Iran shut off
the spigot stop sending them money stop
allowing them to get massive money from
oil they're just going to continue to
funnel that through terrorism Biden has
been a total disaster when it comes to
playing footsie with the Iranian
stop doing that and understand that Iran
wants to fund terrorism it's
inexplicable isn't it I I will never for
the life of me understand why you would
open up and allow Iran to become so
filthy rich uh and allow them to get
back in the world market oil and why
you'd give them billions of dollars it
makes no sense Governor um great to see
you thank you for your time tonight we
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else